deux attaquants moins de quinze jours
largement de quoi susciter l'émoi à
travers tout pays et conduire le premier
ministre jean castex a porté le plan
vigipirate au niveau urgence attentat
sur le plus élevé objectif pour le
gouvernement assure une mobilisation
exceptionnelle des moyens à sa
disposition
la réponse du gouvernement sera ferme
implacable et immédiate
j'ai d'ores et déjà j'ai d'ores et déjà
décidé de porter le plan vigipirate au
niveau d'urgence attentat sur l'ensemble
du territoire national
créé il ya quatre ans lors du
quinquennat de françois hollande pour
faire face à une menace terroriste
grandissante après notamment les
attaques contre charlie hebdo le
bataclan et l'hyper cacher de la porte
de vincennes ce niveau d' alerte vient
renforcer le dispositif de sécurité
esquissé après l'attentât de mai 1978
contre l'aéroport d'orly perpétré par le
fils du sud liban cela porte donc le
plan vigipirate à trois niveaux le
premier engage sans des 300 mesures du
plan vigipirate
le deuxième baptisé sécurité renforcée
en active 216
enfin le troisième niveau prévoit des
mesures exceptionnelles comme l' alerte
enlèvement la fermeture des routes et
des métros ou encore la suspension des
sorties scolaires et le confinement des
écoles après l'annnonce de jean castex
gérard darmanin ministre de l'intérieur
a détaillé les mesures décidées par le
conseil de défense convoqué par emmanuel
macron le conseil de défense a décidé de
l'augmentation de notre posture de
vigilance trois mille cinq cents
gendarmes réservistes vont être appelés
est mis à disposition des préfets dès
lundi ainsi que trois mille cinq cents
policiers et gendarmes mobiles une
riposte du gouvernement qui entraîne une
augmentation des effectifs de protection
sur l'ensemble du territoire
l'opération sentinelle passe de 3000 à
7000 militaires 120 policiers
supplémentaires sont dépêchés à nice et
3500 gendarmes réservistes sont rappelés
un déploiement en cours selon la
ministre des armées
il va monter en puissance nous ne
céderons rien au terrorisme
cette riposte avait été il
quelques jours plus tôt après
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit l'exécutif
avait alors promis une réponse ferme
reposant sur des opérations de police
renforcés des interpellations massives
et un projet de dissolution de plusieurs
associations musulmanes des mesures que
certains dans l'opposition juge
insuffisantes face à la gravité de la
situation on mène cette guerre avec un
corset des boulets aux pieds
il faut qu'on arrête ces délires avec le
droit d'asile des voiliers l'ouverture
totale de nos frontières l'immigration
massive à considérer dérégulé ont été
des drames nous avons aussi accorder la
nationalité française à des personnes
sans mesurer s'il l'a mérité où nous
nous avons le droit d'être exigeant
citron de projets d'attentats ont bien
été déjoué depuis 2010 est depuis le
d'attac contre charlie hebdo
la france a subi une bonne trentaine d'
attaques terroristes qui ont causé la
mort de 250 personnes en 2020 le pays
des lumières semble plus que jamais
désigné comme la cible principale du
terrorisme islamiste